One of the stage that is looked most closely.
In fact,
the only state that's look closely at race discrimination and the death penalty
is North Carolina.
And we're joined today with Henderson Hill,
the distinguished North Carolina lawyer to talk about the experience of North
Carolina with its racial Justice Act.
Uh,
Henderson,
thank you so much for being with us here today.
Steve.
I'm happy to be here.
Thank you.
Well,
glad to have gun.
I W would you just tell us,
tell us about the,
the racial justice act in North Carolina,
what it provided and how it made a difference in terms of the way courts looked
at race discrimination in death penalty cases.
Well,
sure.
One of the things that we became painfully aware of and had been for a good long
while was at a solid citizens hard working members of the community were being
excluded from participation in the criminal justice system.
And it became really very clear in the capital cases that increasingly capital
trials were tried before jurors that were entirely white.
And,
uh,
the supreme court had of course,
had a mechanism for dealing with racial discrimination.
Jury selection,
the bats in three step process was that mechanism.
And in North Carolina it just was not very effective.
In fact,
it was less effective than North Carolina than in many of the southern states.
And the death battles
be there for a second.
When you say the bats and process,
you mean where after the prosecution has struck African Americans?
The defense objects,
the prosecution gives reasons and then the judge decides whether there's a race
discrimination based on the number of black struck and the reasons given by the
prosecutor.
That's correct.
And it's in that second step of the process where the reasons are offered.
That was so frustrating to litigators and observers of the system because in
that second step,
uh,
the,
the explanations race neutral explanations were so clearly pretextual having to
do with,
uh,
the directness of eye contact,
body language,
um,
where they went to school,
whether or not they had children,
the age of the defendant,
whether they were the age of the defendant,
whether they had family members,
uh,
who were involved in the court system.
All of these questions,
which first of all had little or nothing to do with their,
their capacity to serve as jurors.
Uh,
but increasingly those questions were not the same questions at white citizens
call to jury service.
We're were being asked.
And so we were struggling as a state,
as a community of criminal justice officials with how to tap into that.
And of course we had a scene McClaskey and you know,
it's mclass way was rightfully viewed as one of the more shameful opinions and
the Supreme Court's history particularly shameful,
was the notion that we could recognize that race had an undue impact on the
operation of the system.
But it was too difficult to tease out.
And it really wasn't the federal judiciary responsibility to try to tease that
out.
And if you tried to tease that out,
the whole fabric would fall apart.
That's a frustrating response to get from the spring court and looking at the
courts invitation to the,
to the state legislatures to create a fix.
Good people in our legislature said,
well,
let's try to create a fix.
And so in 2009,
we pass the racial justice act,
which said that,
you know,
if in fact race played an undue role in either the decision to seek the death
penalty to impose the death penalty or in selecting jurors to preside or to sit
in they,
uh,
in the trial,
that showing could lead to the reversal of the death sentence and an imposition
of a sentence of life without parole.
Uh,
it was a historic piece of legislation.
importantly,
one of the things that,
uh,
two things,
two important features,
one was a statistical evidence,
scientific evidence would be admissible and for many years,
one of the frustrations where we were not able to admit statistical evidence of
discrimination in our classic lawsuit in our classic motions.
Well,
this was an expression by the general assembly saying that in the criminal
justice arena,
just like in the public health arena,
just like an industry,
uh,
in every other walk of life science would be allowed into evidence.
And so there was an open invitation to include statistical and scientific
evidence.
Uh,
and that was incredibly helpful.
I think the other part that I thought was very dramatic and very important was a
suggestion.
Though we're not necessarily accusing prosecutors and judges of racial Animus,
we're not suggesting that what,
what are jurors and are confronted with and you know,
2010,
2012 his bowl Connor or the folks who believe the,
the African American jurors,
no more than monkeys.
And it's not that level of animus.
What we are talking about is a legacy in the courthouse of regarding African
American jurors,
citizens as something less than full citizens,
either intellectually or as a part of morality or with respect to some
prosecutors who were more interested in just winning.
If,
if it was viewed that black jurors were an obstacle to winning,
securing the death sentence for whatever reasons,
the prosecutor may not have racial Animus,
but he connects race to a particular outcome independent of what the jurors
actual feelings are on the relevant questions.
And so I thought the,
the General Assembly,
uh,
was,
was looking for discriminatory impact as opposed to a discriminatory intent.
And I think that was an important innovation in the,
in the law.
And when you went out and gathered this statistics and presented them to the
court,
what did you find?
Well,
Steve,
it was overwhelmingly powerful.
According to the statute.
We were tasked with identifying the impacts both on a statewide basis,
on a countywide basis.
And then on the individual case itself.
And the consistency of the numbers were just mind boggling.
You know,
which ever way you looked at it.
And you know,
if you are African American,
you were somewhere between two and a half to three times more likely to be
excluded from jury service then if you were white.
Now of course that did vary with respect to counties.
And so some counties it was dramatically high or,
and so in some counties that we consistently hover closer to the three or exceed
three and other counties,
that would be a closer to the two of.
But when you,
one of the things,
I'm not a statistician,
that's not my training,
uh,
but I've had some invaluable contact with the researchers.
Uh,
Katherine Grosso and Barbara Brian.
And these differences too that are incredibly long.
I mean,
you're talking about three times.
The likelihood of being excluded.
If you African American then if you're
a white citizen,
that kind of ratio is incredibly powerful.
If you go,
it's based on,
it was this based on an analysis of all the jury strikes and capital cases all
over the state of North Carolina.
What yes,
what they did and it was an enormous effort.
I think it was 173 cases,
uh,
that went to,
that received the death sentence.
They polled every single juror,
every single citizen that was called for jury service.
In those cases,
in,
in almost all of those cases,
there were questionnaires,
often very voluminous questionnaires.
Um,
there was long transcripts.
One thing about North Carolina is you have fairly broad Vardy and so the
transcripts go thousands of pages.
They're often weeks long jury,
the questioning of the jurors.
That's rare in the jury selection process.
That's exactly right.
And so these researchers use literally scores of law students and some certified
attorneys,
uh,
to go out to the county courthouses to pull,
above the questionnaires.
The clerks had their own charts where recorded and calculated the strikes
peremptory and cause drawings for the government,
for the state and by the court.
All of these original documents were secured,
uh,
and,
and process by these independent researches and,
and the staff of law students and investigators that they supervise.
Uh,
it was an enormous effort.
there are thousands,
I believe the actual number was somewhere between seven and 8,000 citizens whose
responses were evaluated under a,
this incredibly complicated ma methodology.
Um,
and the results were,
were,
were simply powerful and eventually those results were presented to the court
and Cumberland County,
they're in North Carolina and a couple of cases.
Indeed,
uh,
it,
it first started,
first of all,
I should say that we attempted to organize with the district,
with the district attorney's,
uh,
sort of orderly way in orderly process of litigating the cases.
We had meetings with the DA,
with the ags office to see if we could come up with sort of a complex litigation
strategy.
Uh,
in the end they,
they declined.
They didn't want an orderly process to it.
And so as it happens,
it was sort of left to a random selection of when a particular case would be
filed and who would bid it on for hearing.
Uh,
and we ended up with the first case being litigated in Cumberland County.
as it happens,
uh,
the senior residence period court judge was,
Cumberland County was a,
uh,
a judge named Greg weeks who was perhaps the most,
well,
one of the most well respected trial judges in the state.
Uh,
incredibly bright,
incredibly fair,
uh,
and skilled with respect to criminal practice and criminal procedures.
Very well thought of in the county and in the state.
And he conducted a hearing after a,
and you'll appreciate this Dave,
after several motions of contingent to continue by the state,
right,
he bent over backwards to afford them every procedural opportunity to get ready
for this,
the study that we hit prepared.
And they had claimed that they wanted to do some independent research and he
gave them time to do that,
uh,
to amend their response to our study.
Uh,
and so there was an extensive hearing where the researches and gave,
you know,
days and days and days of testimony regarding the methodology,
um,
the sourcing of the documents and then the statistical analysis.
And you know,
even for a non lawyer at that time I had left,
I,
I had left the,
the trial team,
but I sort of watched from a distance.
It's a testimony came in.
Uh,
and the statistical evidence was really quite overwhelming.
one of the things that I thought made it powerful,
both as a piece of litigation but also as a method,
as a vehicle for public education was in addition to the statistics,
there was a good amount of anecdotal testimony about the practices and
Cumberland County,
uh,
in,
in very significant significant part,
you had sick the senior members of the bar,
all of them white who offered affidavits about their exposure to,
uh,
the sort of discriminatory practices in the county.
And even these affidavits of lawyers who were not willing to suggest that there
was racial animus by the assistant district attorneys.
And in fact,
the,
on one of those senior district attorneys.
And someone that I know and know very well and I would hesitate to accuse him of
racial animus.
Uh,
but patterns develop or even in the absence of Animus,
there was a consistent pattern of African American jurors being excluded at
these enormously high rates.
Um,
and,
and that was a piece of particular,
particularly powerful evidence.
So what you saw here is while you might look at one case and c five
African-american Struck,
and it may not be that impressive when you put all the cases together,
the evidence was just too much to be a,
you just couldn't be a matter of chance.
That's exactly right.
Over the course of 173 cases,
and I forget now how many of the hundred counties in North Carolina had death
sentences.
You,
you never found a county where the ratio was one,
one for one w which would be the statistical evidence of a perfect equality.
Could a person
black has just as much chance of being struck or a person who is white has just
as much chance of being struck,
right?
I mean,
there were those aberrations where you'd have a,
a county to the far west of the Far East where they just didn't use the death
penalty very much.
And so he had very little statistical basis.
Uh,
and so some of that cases,
some of the evidence there was weaker,
less powerful than in others.
But even in those cases,
you know,
the ratios were still in a suggestive of discrimination in Cumberland County
itself.
One of the powerful anecdotes was,
uh,
the cases of Burmeister and right.
And these were the two young white men who went in Cumberland county hunting for
black people to kill them.
He found some black people killing.
They killed him.
Uh,
interestingly in that case,
uh,
you know,
I think there were 10 African American jurors,
uh,
who were passed,
I believe,
nine of them,
uh,
or pass by the state,
which was incredible.
I mean,
polluted from service struck by that.
No,
no,
they weren't.
They were allowed Paul out.
I'm sorry.
Bye.
By the district attorney.
You know,
the,
the one case where the discrimination was,
I think 0.5 happened to be in the case where the white defendants were charged
with racially charged killings of African American jurors.
In that one case,
the prosecutors decided that,
oh,
these African American jurors,
they can be fair.
You looked at the questionnaires and those questionnaires had all of the same
characteristics of African American jurors that you had contacts with criminal
justice system.
You had,
uh,
you know,
the same,
historically black colleges attended all of the same things that they would in
other cases used to exclude in that particular case they use because they
believe race meant something.
And so they,
they purposely sat,
you know,
African American jurors in that racially charged case with white defendants.
Uh,
so it's sort of a,
we looked at it as a flip of the racial dynamic,
but it was still powerful evidence of the racial dynamic in that particular,
uh,
prosecuting office that race matters.
Race matters.
In fact,
race was pivotal.
Race was determinative of the voir dire jury selection strategy of the district
attorney.
Now,
what are the other anecdotal piece of evidence was this cheat sheet,
right?
It's by the prosecutor.
I and Steve,
I'm not quite sure how that came to light.
I,
you know,
I'm getting up in age,
I just can't remember how it came.
But what we learned was,
uh,
in 1995,
the North Carolina and District Attorney Association conducted one of their
teaching seminars for the district attorneys from across the state.
And it was actually entitled the top guns seminar,
meaning the elite of the district attorneys,
the assistant district attorneys would come.
These would be the ones who were or practicing capital litigation.
And in that seminar,
what they did was they literally prepared a cheat sheet of excuses.
Protect is for excluding African Americans.
And if you remembered Justice Marshall Thurgood Marshall's opinion,
I think it was like a concurring opinion in Batson where he said,
this three step process isn't going to work because we can imagine,
uh,
that they're going,
if you can so easily overcome a prime aphasia showing of,
of discrimination by asking the litigant to come up with reasons,
well,
that's going to be an illusory protection eye protection because it'd be so easy
to overcome.
And in fact with this top gun sheep,
all you had to do is go through the 15 reasons,
uh,
eye contact,
body language,
uh,
slow to respond.
Um,
you know,
they simply,
it was a list of basically a list of race nude for reasons.
So when the,
uh,
prosecutor struck on African American and the judge said,
why you're just looked down at the list and picked one of the reasons you just
pick a handful,
right?
There'd be 15 reasons you pick your top four or five.
And those that seem to be most fitting,
uh,
with respect to the particular case or the particular juror.
Uh,
and I mean,
it really did shine a light on the credibility of the,
uh,
of the approach of the district attorneys and to know that what they're being
trained and how they're being,
uh,
schools,
not to protect the rights of good,
hardworking citizens who respond to a summons for were for jury service,
but they actually using this as a ploy to exclude those persons from a basic
responsibility and right of citizenship.
Um,
and so
it was as disappointing as a member of the profession,
as disappointing as a member of the community to know that our public officials
are being trained in that way to,
to basically trample on the basic rights of citizens.
Well,
you mentioned this case went before one of the most senior and a respected
judges in,
in North Carolina.
Uh,
how,
how did he handle,
or what was his determination of the evidence that was presented by both the
prosecution and the defense in this case?
Well,
as I mentioned,
uh,
he gave both sides,
you know,
clear room as litigated to present their case.
And I should say that the case that was presented,
the study that was presented by the district attorney as it,
as it turned out,
was really just a collection of surveys that had been sent out.
The district attorneys and the survey responses were basically the questions
like,
did you intend to discriminate against African Americans?
What was your approach to jury selection?
And those sorts of questions.
And it would not be surprising to note that most of the district attorney's that
responded said they had no racial animus and they were colorblind and their jury
selection.
So the judge went through and very workman like fashion,
the evidence that was submitted at trial that the,
um,
the very peer reviewed study from the Michigan State University researchers,
the independent statistician that had reviewed the study,
uh,
concurred with their approach.
We had,
uh,
we had a,
an expert in and race in the criminal justices.
Uh,
a person very well known to you,
Bryan Stevenson,
who talked about similar studies in other southern states where the death
penalty is employed.
He had an opportunity to not only the study,
but also the anecdotal evidence that was submitted.
So judge,
judge weeks reviewed the entirety of that testimony and not with reluctance,
but it was one of the most sober opinions you're going to read from a district,
from,
uh,
from a sitting superior court.
And I thought it was just,
it was eloquent.
I mean,
it,
it goes,
it went actually back to the history of slavery and Jim Crow and w w without at
all calling any of the participants,
the district attorney,
the prosecutor's,
uh,
the law enforcement officer's racist or even suggesting that they were racist,
identify the problem with the,
some legacies of discrimination that then it's sort of tore it his heart because
this was his home county impacted the process and he's in his court house.
And so I think while it may have been a very sober,
uh,
opinion,
it was a powerful one because it reviewed,
uh,
the evidence that was presented and the evidence he was quite simply
overwhelming,
both statistical and anecdotal and yeah,
as litigators when you're,
when you're in receipt of that kind of overwhelming evidence that the systems
that you as a lawyer support and work with them,
that they are systematically being used to target and deprive hardworking
citizens of participation in the system.
It's a hard thing to accept when it's in black and white like that.
And so I think the opinion that came out,
Steve had had to be a hundred page long order and it just sort of,
and work,
been lying fashion just sort of work through the evidence and,
and,
and one of the things that you,
there was,
there was tremendous evidence on implicit racism that what we're talking about
here is not any sort of conscious decision of district attorneys,
uh,
to Shane criticized,
demean African American citizens.
But part of the legacy is that the view that African Americans,
you know,
look at the government differently.
Look at crime differently,
value crime victims differently.
That's some of the baggage that we walk around with.
And,
uh,
it was,
Professor Summers,
uh,
from,
I think it was Tufts.
I've been in Boston that presented some powerful evidence about implicit bias.
Uh,
and this is just the way folks organize their information.
It doesn't reflect Animus,
but it reflects a convenience.
It reflects,
um,
shortcuts to reaching conclusions.
We all do it.
Uh,
and it's just that,
you know,
when,
when you,
when things become sort of received notions of truth about who's strong for law
enforcement or who's antigovernment,
those things help people organize the way they look at the world and how you
look at the citizens and the jury box.
And those are the biases that the study reflected.
And ultimately,
uh,
the judge weeks said violates our constitution.
Uh,
and most clearly violate the racial justice act.
Really a combination of history,
culture,
and unconscious or implicit racial attitudes that are the three pieces there,
right?
The three pieces came together,
uh,
and,
and fit in a way that was,
I think every observer of the hearing thought was overwhelming.
Um,
yeah,
I have not seen as,
as,
as one sided a,
uh,
an important legal engagement as that litigation was one sided,
not because of the amount of resources that were available to one side or the
other.
You went into the courtroom,
you know,
there are plenty of lawyers over there,
the lawyers over there had the benefit of all of the statewide resources of the
attorney general's office and everything else.
It was one sided,
Steve based on justice,
substantive evidence,
the scientific approach to the efforts,
the,
the professional management of the evidence and have the witnesses.
Um,
that was literally one of the most one sided pieces of litigation I,
I've seen.
And what was I think scary to people who were opposed to the,
uh,
to the objectives of the racial justice act is looking down the road,
looking at the future,
it was hard to see how that dynamic would change.
It was hard to see,
you know,
what would be the best scientific criticism of the study.
Yeah.
How would you attack some of the anecdotal evidence,
uh,
that was presented.
And I imagine those,
those folks struggled mightily with that.
Yeah,
I should say there were some strategic considerations from our side that
influenced it,
you know,
the Racial Justice Act talk not just about jury selection but about the decision
to seek the death penalty and the decision to impose to them.
I don't see those parts were involved in a separate study by the same
researchers and Michigan State University and I for one and not a statistician.
Uh,
it could see in their report that the strengths of those other parts of the
study wasn't as clear,
wasn't as strong as the jury selection study.
And so we made some strategic decisions that those parts of the study,
we would not deal with us at this heroic,
we essentially bifurcated the litigation between the jury selection part of the
study and the decision to seek the death penalty on the district attorney's
farm.
Uh,
and just as a matter of science,
it would have been a much more complicated hearing to show that the decision to
seek the death penalty violated the statute and or the constitution.
I think if we had made a different strategic move and put the entire study in,
uh,
in litigation,
things would not have been perhaps as clear,
perhaps as overwhelming as it was with the sort of bifurcated part.
And I think,
uh,
once that decision was made and you all know Kenny rose and ty hunter,
Jim Ferguson,
we were all part Jim Cooney,
we're all part of that decision.
You know,
that decision went a long way towards having a as clear an outcome,
a decision by the court and as overwhelming and evidentiary basis supporting
that decision as we could have imagined.
Uh,
sometimes Steve,
you win too much.
Well,
I was gonna
say,
I mean this is a very disturbing finding by a senior judge,
a respect to judge there in North Carolina.
I believe there were two cases in which judge weeks found,
uh,
that race was a significant factor and therefore the,
the death census had to be set aside.
Uh,
what was the response of North Carolina,
uh,
to these disturbing findings about the fact that race had played such a role in
the selection of juries there and North Carolina?
Well,
uh,
there was the one case,
Marcus Robinson was the first case after that three cases were combined.
And so there was a second
piece of litigation,
second set of hearings.
But they combine three cases in that,
in that second case,
uh,
the same kind of evidence.
Many of the same witnesses were called,
uh,
the government had obviously more of an opportunity to be prepared for the,
the nature of the evidence.
And Steve,
uh,
their presentation,
the second was no stronger,
no more effective than the first.
And in fact,
you know,
as a criminal defense lawyer,
you rarely look forward to retrials because you think the other side is more
prepared.
You shot a gun,
you know,
you've,
you've exposed your evidence,
surely they'll have all these powerful comebacks.
Well,
Steve,
that wasn't the case here.
Um,
this is one of those situations where just the merits of the evidence,
both statistical and anecdotal,
it didn't matter if they had another six months to go after it,
you know,
a doubling of their budget to go after it,
know they were not going to change,
uh,
the essential facts of the litigation.
And they didn't.
And if anything,
because of the three cases,
we had more anecdotes to pick from.
Uh,
just sort of add to the spice of things,
uh,
at that hearing than,
than,
uh,
the,
earlier hearing.
Uh,
the result was that it was exactly the same.
but I believe it was in between those two hearings.
Steve,
if,
I'm not sure,
I've got the dates precisely in mind,
but I think it was shortly after the Marcus Robinson hearing,
but before the golfing hearings that the repeal of the Racial Justice Act
happening,
uh,
and there were negotiations,
first of all,
there was the amendment of the Racial Justice Act,
uh,
which you know,
was sort of a compromise reached by the partisans at the General Assembly,
uh,
where they need to essential provisions.
One is that statistical evidence by itself,
uh,
it could not result in the overturning of a death sentence.
Uh,
and basically what that meant is you'd have to provide anecdotes,
descriptions of discriminatory behavior by the local district attorney or the
court system.
And,
uh,
the second provision was that you,
you'd have to show evidence within the case itself,
the defendant's case itself,
uh,
that he was subjected to actions that were discriminatory.
Uh,
and,
and I believe that happened.
The amendment happened before the second suit,
say second set of litigation didn't change the outcome both because the
litigators were prepared with the anecdotal evidence,
the non statistical evidence to supplement the work by the researchers from
Michigan State University.
And that included evidence of,
you know,
race specific discriminatory,
specific stuff,
uh,
in,
in the,
in the case itself.
Um,
you know,
one of the things,
Steve,
that,
uh,
has been powerful in the litigation and the preparation of these cases is once
you get past the statistical evidence,
and for some of us it's this trickle evidence is it's not boring,
but it can all talk about that for so long.
Right?
I mean,
the results are,
you know,
56% of African Americans are excluded,
24% are white,
and they'll vary from county to county.
They are very over time.
But you know,
that's basically the band of that evidence.
You know,
what's so disturbing or these affidavits from individual citizens,
um,
uh,
affidavits from jurors who,
you know,
who misrepresented things in their questionnaire,
um,
uh,
about their own histories with violence or with rays.
And these things came up the,
the rouse opinion where a one white juror simply didn't tell Fox that his mother
had been murdered by an African American and he thought that all black men were
violent and he didn't feel the need to share that in jury selection.
Well,
that's not part of the study.
That's not part of the research piece,
but does it inform the,
uh,
the,
the quality of justice in that county,
those post conviction motions?
Uh,
Roe v,
which revealed that bias we're were made shortly after the trial.
It didn't affect the post conviction core.
Okay.
Didn't provide any relief.
So we're now through the guise of the racial justice act,
looking a conviction and a death sentence that ignored the fact that a juror
literally misrepresentative not lied under oath under questioning and kept from
the litigators evidence that was critical to his fairness to sit in the trial.
And our court system said that didn't matter.
Okay.
Uh,
it's a,
it's a sort of constant refrain that the value and the quality of African
American citizens and it just doesn't measure up to the value and the
appreciation given,
uh,
to citizens who are white who are responding to their call,
call to duty.
And it's just,
it was just a constant drumbeat of evidence of evidence after evidence if that's
the case and counties throughout the state.
Um,
one of the tragedies I see,
uh,
we're not quite sure what the effect of the other repeal of the racial Justice
Act will be.
It's truly the legislature after that amendment that you talked about after the
second hearing,
the actually repeal the act or is that correct?
That's correct.
Um,
and you know,
we're still litigating with the impact of that repeal is,
but you know,
after the elections of 2010 then elections of 2012,
uh,
the partisans opponents had control of the State House,
state Senate,
and the governor's seat.
And they simply ran the table on the racial justice act and just took it off the
books and see if you'll note that it was the same running of the table that
resulted in the most outrageous,
most notorious voter suppression legislation in the country.
You can't really keep them separate.
It's part of the same initiative.
Uh,
but with respect to the racial justice act,
it took the racial justice act off the books.
Now for the hundred and 58 people who had filed petitions.
And those petitions are in one state of litigation or another.
It's not clear whether that repeal,
how that repeal will affect their rights.
We're continuing to litigate those cases.
Uh,
but one of the things is absolutely painful to me is that the public education
that goes on in the litigation of these cases and in the small county
courthouses,
uh,
of our state and getting enormous publicity in that county and as such,
a missed opportunity,
uh,
for public education for our young voters are middle aged voters to see what
happens in the courthouse.
Right.
You know,
people are not,
uh,
often attuned to the country and the state civil rights history.
They even less attuned often to what happens in their county courthouse.
And the Racial Justice Act Litigation was an opportunity to bring all of that
fairly remarkable history,
local history,
uh,
before the eyes of,
you know,
local citizens at the county level,
at the municipal level.
And yeah,
I think there's just very few public education vehicles,
as powerful as,
as the litigation and the racial justice act is a tragedy to shut that door,
to prevent our citizens from having that educational experience.
And of course in other states that educational experience is not taking place
because there is no racial justice act.
And it's,
uh,
certainly sobering at the North Carolina legislature upon finding,
have judicial findings of race entering into the,
the influencing these capital cases instead of dealing with the fact that race
is entering into them,
repeal the racial Justice Act so that,
uh,
no longer would those issues be discussed with that public education and take
place and would,
uh,
um,
the state grapple with the issue of race and,
and,
and the death pollack basically that's off the table now,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
it,
it's a shameful,
it's a shameful occurrence and,
uh,
you know,
it's hard,
hard to know,
um,
because the,
the thing has become such a partisan issue,
right?
Eh,
how,
how people of goodwill,
uh,
people good faith can endorse the strategy which shuts the door and that kind of
public education,
uh,
without thinking or suggesting that they harbor some inappropriate biases.
Um,
yeah.
And yeah,
it does it help to suggest that it's part of a partisan agendas of the people
can join in that agenda without sharing,
uh,
the animus or the bias.
Yeah.
It's like counting the angels on the head of a pin.
It's an exercise I find futile.
Uh,
but it's,
it,
it's painful.
The result is something that's painful.
Uh,
I'm not sure how we reverse,
uh,
that kind of decision.
So as a matter of state public policy as a matter of,
uh,
you,
yeah,
educational potential in the state.
I don't know how we get back the opportunity to present a witness like Bryan
Stevenson and to have his testimony covered locally by radio stations,
local newspapers,
and to have someone of that quality review,
the evidence has been presented and we'll link that to the history and legacy of
racism and race discrimination in our justice system in the south.
That's an opportunity that you're not going to often get in Cumberland county.
It's not an opportunity to,
you're often gone to get and union county,
North Carolina and Duplin County,
North Carolina,
and that's what the Racial Justice Act afforded the citizens of North Carolina.
And we've lost that now.
Well Henderson Hell,
thank you very much for describing this time and what the state of North
Carolina did and what they found and uh,
it's immensely helpful for us understanding me.
Thanks.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Save.
Good luck.